because if it was open and I can see
what's inside then I'd be told hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to song of horror now this game
is currently out on Kickstarter and it
is in its final hours but I'll give a
recommendation on whether or not it
should be funded after I play the game
but I didn't want to mention that I'm
currently wearing my king of the
squirrel shirt it's a brand new shirt
that's being sold for charity it's got
the marklar here's logo on the Left
sleeve and I believe it's going to
Doctors Without Borders this time it's
gonna be a really good cause and this is
limited edition so it will sell out very
soon after I say these words so there's
a link in the description where you can
find this shirt in the store and you can
buy for yourself it's $20 this time it
said 25 for a charity shirt so with that
being said let's get to the game
let's get that mouse out of here so I
got a controller because I loaded this
up and I wanted to see exactly how I
moved and I did not look at the controls
last time so hold run listen that door
with Y open closed inventory interact
push door open okay so what you guys are
gonna see is that this game is actually
made on the Unreal Engine which means it
has a little more graphical fidelity
than anything that unity can do not that
unity makes bad games that's not what
I'm saying but you'll see like the
lighting is a bit better like the
environments are a bit more detailed and
whatnot I mean everything you know it's
not entirely dependent on the engine
that's made on but it is dependent on a
lot of outside sources like work and
stuff like that but it does allow more
flexibility so oh okay so that's what
listening into a door is but why would I
need to listen to a door unless there's
gonna be a horrible monstrosity on the
other side which is probably the case
okay so the story is I actually had to
go into the pause 'men it won't open
okay good for me Daniel arrives at the
hussar mansion searching for Sebastian P
huh sure famous writer who is absolutely
missing no question about that
absolutely upon arrival he finds the
door is open but it seems that nobody's
around he decided to fulfill his
objective Daniel enters the house in
search of mr. huh sure so that's the
story of why we're here but this is a
demo so it's not entirely this is what
the developers want to say it's not
reflective of the final game and who
knows if the final game is going to be
in
readily different not very different you
never know but I'm gonna play this
because a half documented chance but
everything that I've seen about this
game need a key to open this door okay
so I should remember that I suppose now
I will admit the controls are a little
wonky like it wasn't controlling exactly
like I thought it would be doing when I
first loaded this game up because
there's a lot of stop and start that I
have to do but I imagine that's just
sensing getting sued a tribal mask
seeing a novel not very important for me
so should I go in these doors well I
guess I can't go upstairs right now
because it's appears to be blocked off
yeah whoops man wait well will will will
it's as if someone didn't want me to go
upstairs yeah maybe the developers
because game's not done yet I will admit
that it does have is that annoyance it's
important to me or is that bad it does
have a lot of like Resident Evil Silent
Hill vibes to the controls and whatnot
and kind of the elements in fear of the
fixed camera perspective kind of gives
that idea yeah see uh if it looks like
I'm just not confident at playing games
at all by walking into walls and objects
it's it's not my fault this game
actually it's a little different in the
controls than anything I've seen before
because it's a very turn-based you know
just just it doesn't go where the camera
where you think you want to go for the
game okay how about inspect I'm
inspecting use this isn't working I
don't know what you wanted to do it's a
match box I've never seen one before
would here see a whole lot of nothing ah
did I mention this game is demo quite a
number of books on the other hand
probably normal for a writer's house
yeah wouldn't you know it being a weirdo
snooping around this guy's house
I was absolutely missing why not take it
upon yourself Daniel Daniels do tend to
get themselves in trouble farther in the
game that I've seen I mean in other
games that I've seen not that I know
what I've talked about right now light
okay you almost got it on target there
pretty close Olo you hi whoa okay I can
move flashing alright then thank you
hello pushers briefcase apparently kind
of weird that he left it here if he's
out unless he wasn't headed for work
well I mean he's a writer what does he
have to do the drawers stuck it sounds
like there's something in it how does it
sound like there's something in it I
don't understand you logic behind that
one but apparently this guy's the
world's greatest detective what a mess
this looks like home is that just
commentary on the slob lifestyle that
you live the sheer amount of books could
easily bury me alive
that's a weird thought that's an oddly
specific thought to have when you look
at a shelf of books I mean I don't often
talk about being buried alive in my
normal day-to-day life let alone when
I'm snooping around someone else's house
so there is a phone in the house huh
sure must have been out when I called
him each of the 30 times okay what why
what do I need to hide under something
what do you mean I need to hide out or
something what are you talking about
what oh you could go a little faster how
about this
this one
hello Sammy hello someone there is
anybody there
oh oh I have no idea what to Sabbat have
it I have no idea what just happened
what happened
all right we're just gonna love that
it's gonna leave that one alone all
right then
I'm assuming there was a monster
somewhere but why did I know that I
needed to hide I mean this is a demo
obviously it's just a proof of concept
than anything but I didn't find a key
there was a door that I needed to key to
oh hello
Oh was this open before yeah I think I
went into Purdue I go in here before
I don't know oh yeah I did oh that was
not lit before was it can't remember a
pendulum clock my grandparents used to
have a similar one it'd be blow high
whoa Jesus oh okay scare over now that
was cool I guess I'm supposed to go in
here I didn't even know this door was
here well alrighty then this Meho nice
camera perspective really helps me on my
adventures Oh God
creepy creepy creepy I didn't mean to
pick that up okay Wow look at it go look
at it it's a dancing stream Dean oh it's
so beautiful I don't know what I'd use
it on I can't use this item here good I
forgot that I had an inventory oh man I
didn't even know this was all over here
for God's sake what's this awful stench
I don't know they're maggots squirming
in the pot maybe it's the maggots but I
have no idea
okay another piece of story that I
didn't get nothing to see yet nobody has
washed these implements in a while I'm
guessing cuz he's missing sea water salt
pepper a recipe book for traditional
Russian cuisine so it's a Russian guy oh
I got a key okay cool so I know where to
use this okay this isn't working
obviously because you don't use it on
thin air stupid but Oh God come on man
control is this what is this to my right
there we go I thought it was a door of
course I can't open it not I bet this
one won't work
oh it will work okay what do you mean
Daniel did not make it
what oh I was supposed to listen to that
door I didn't know I was supposed to
listen to that door
well that was hardly helpful for my
everyday life Daniel didn't make it for
God's sake first Daniel didn't make it
he didn't know what was gonna happen to
him oh I got to start a new game well
damn it already then there's something
fun
yeah that doesn't sound too good all
righty then I'll be on my way I'm gonna
flip on the light his monsters are
afraid of light and that's what I've
learned in everything I've ever done let
me just put this piece of paper just so
I have it I don't know if it's important
for the story but I know that I'm gonna
take it any oh good the lights flicker
on and off when I leave a room okay so
what was it about this door that got
unlocked obviously oh it did okay
oh this is the remote oh no it's not
okay
so there was God okay all right little
randomize a little randomize not bad
with the handprints on the wall a little
bit of a jump to silence there okay so
go I got to start listening on all the
doors now
that is eerie that is eerie that's gonna
be a really interesting game mechanic if
that's in the final product
oh boy here hello hi there my name's
Buckingham Terence the lorry okay this
one didn't open because the other one it
open okay to the keys to this one which
I imagine goes down to the basement well
you have a key open it up use the key I
don't know which one of these is the key
use there we go okay so let me listen to
it first because probably death is not
on the other side but I just want to be
kur careful careful
I want to be careful I want to be real
careful about this one hello hi light
work yes good oh that just makes it
worse is death on this door don't look
at the light yeah yeah I know
come on listen to this door
okay door probably doesn't go anywhere
cuz if I'm thinking about the layout of
the house is flexible yeah this is like
some shining bull with how the Hound
Hotel was laid out just some impossible
geometry going on
what is that these there are notes about
domestic chores and timetables here
others are written in C relief I don't
know what that means
man this it slows things down if I have
to listen to every door that I go behind
other one's gonna die
I guess I guess that's another good
alternative but you know just kind of
want to figure out everything before I
die see everything I want to experience
it all I love special lubricant oil-- oh
the oil you trust hey then ah should I
run now let's dive ever okay that guy
look very scared about that alrighty
then let's here
that sounds bad but I can know for
certain till I open the door let's go
all right goodbye door of hell I've got
oil oh I don't know what Boileau is for
oh maybe the drawer that was stuck
can I please there we go someone's
filled a jar with various fine sand
maybe the guy that lives in this house
that I'm breaking into maybe just maybe
maybe oh maybe it might be his okay so
that door but what about this Dorothea
no way oh that was grabbable
not important can't even read it okay
this door
oh that's so creepy my closet door is
open
I don't remember opening it door oh that
is weird
that is really weird that it's really
weird that closet door is never open oh
no serious I'm not even joking you guys
my closet door is open right now and
it's never open it's never open Ryan are
you in there no okay oh well that's so
weird
you know you don't know how
disconcerting it is because it's right
over that it's right over there and it's
open but it's not open all the way it's
open just a crack which makes it even
weirder because I can't see what's
inside it because if it was open and I
can see what's inside then I'd be told
okay all right I'm okay I'm okay
okay okay okay so I'm pretty sure this
might be did the oil I need
maybe it'll lubricate up the door I've
got a rag that I could use with it or
the drawer the drawer was either stuck
or it was locked or something one of the
other
this drawer stuck okay so if I use this
is the oil yeah we'll use that I think I
agree sit with the oil so do it
okay there we go got it what do we got
there's a key inside key to what I don't
know what this key goes to the briefcase
uh how about do it do I open the
briefcase no probably not
okay so there's got to be another door
that this key goes to but I don't
remember another door being locked
anywhere maybe there's something in here
for this planetarium here not blender
that door is still still not looking fun
still not looking fun and why even like
I don't even care who huh sure is why do
I care so much that I'm willing to work
what happened whoa Jesus don't do that
that is weird
that was weird camera work right there
come on oh there was a stool in whatever
okay so there's got to be another door
somewhere around here can I not can I
not go through this door what the hell
okay never mind then oh yeah that's
right oh that's right hide or run very
far I can't run I can't run I can only
me an oh god you stool [ __ ] oh god oh
god oh god oh god okay I know I said I
was gonna go on the open but I don't
want to die again I don't want to go
through all this progress again
it would be scarier if I could see
something you [ __ ] I'm closing that
closet that's [ __ ] [ __ ] club no
way no way
oh god now the door was open who's in
there
[ __ ] I don't like it I don't like it
I don't like it I don't like it what
happened my dad my Jesus guy he's still
doing the thing like my my my my closet
door and my bathroom door were both open
and I closed them all the time I always
closed them I checked out I checked
everything I checked everything no one
in my room okay okay good finally Jesus
sorry I'm okay okay so now I have a key
but I don't know what the key co2 goes
to need a key to open this door got it I
found the lock door goody-goody gumdrops
for me okay use this one perfect oh okay
uh-oh this looks like a fun hallway oh I
can't wait to reverse this oh boy
pretty good good good good oh this is
where I go down into the basement you
know I seem to be diving headfirst into
all this trauma Oh candles good I'm sure
a cults down here fun times for me oh is
that Oh what is that what is that what
is it oh it's a mirror okay never mind
then
there's an old me
okay so that was song of war that
actually had a lot of really interesting
things about it but for being a
Kickstarter demo that was actually
pretty good proof of concept has a lot
of interesting ideas the creeping
through the house like the haunted house
aspect of it is really nice and it adds
a few new elements to it like listening
to the door and being very slow and
methodical about everything if they can
hammer out the control scheme a little
better because it was only slightly
frustrating but I did like the fixed
camera perspective just a little
refining on the subject could be good
for this game and it looks pretty good
too um just because of the engine that
it is needs a little refinement on the
animations but I'll give it to that it's
a demo obviously they're trying to kick
start the game good proof of concept
though I think it has a lot of potential
if you do - there's a link down to the
Kickstarter I'm not funded by this in
any way they're not sponsoring me to do
this I really do think this could be
good there's only a few hours left on
the Kickstarter though so if you want to
support and give it a look links down
there that's all I'll say about it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and do check out the five nights or the
king of the squirrels not five nights
what am I talking about king of the
curls t-shirts
proceeds go to Doctors Without Borders
it's great charity and I hope you guys
will support it Limited Edition only
about 4000 or so or printed so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always Ellis
in the next video the best baby his
nuclear explosion
how's it going there whoa that's my head